Herkese
[Müzik]
merhaba şimdilik bunu kırmızı çizginin
dışında kalmadan kırmızı çizginin dışına
bakayım
konuşmamı hazırlanırken Tabii ki evde
Aynanın karşısına geçip en karizmatik
şekilde nasıl konuşabilirim diye
denemeler yaptım şöyle şeyler yaşadım
Şimdi de bunu deneyeceğim biraz deneysel
olacak ama bakalım olacak mı konu
maskeler olduğu için
hanımefendiler beyefendiler ve sevgili
çocuklar
bu olmadı
bu açılışı nedir bu hostes O yüzden
başka çıkardım Evet şimdi şu maskeyi
deneyim
bu maskenin içinde biraz gözyaşı var
bu maskeler maskeler maskeler
tanıdığımı sandığım tüm yüzler
Bu da kalbi kırılmış umutsuz Şair O
yüzden bunu da bıraktım
şuradan bir maske alalım
program bir yerden yaklaşacak olursak
sahnede olma isteği mi çocukluk
dönemindeki göremediğim İlgiye ilgi
açlığına Hatta arzulanmak isteğine
bağlayabiliriz Ama unutmayalım ki Freud
da çok çizgisiz bir hayat yaşamadı
Bu da Modalı kadıköylü Bu biraz daha
konuşsa tutuklarlar O yüzden bunu da
kenara koyduk Başka bir şey daha
hareketli daha yüksek enerji yüksek
bakalım şurada ya varmış
Evet arkadaşlar kanalıma Hoşgeldiniz
Bu da çok gürültülü Burası için tam son
maskeyi deniyorum
Karlı izleyenler un maskeler aşağı eller
yukarı
bi gösterimize hoş geldin ız bundan
sonra yalanı Rüya Karlı sahtekârlık yara
bırakıyorum bu da çok açık çok dürüst
bir de çok ince de şive Komedisi diye O
yüzden ben şimdi size hiçbir maskem
olmadan sende bu sahnesinde yaptığım
gibi bi maskesiz kendimi Nasıl bulduğumu
anlatayım
ben enerjisi iç enerjisi yüksek bir
insandım hep anaokuluna yazılmak için
görüşmeye gittiğimizde okula müdür
yardımcısının odasında
çarkıfelekten ve annemin dergilerinden
çözdüğünü düşündüğüm okuma
becerilerimizi sergileyerek Bu bir
sınıfa yazıldım beş buçuk yaşında okula
başladım ve dedim ki bu seçim kaybedecek
vakit yok
Yok orta sonda liseye hazırlanırken hem
voleybol oynuyordum tiyatro daydım
sınava hazırlanıyordum dil kursuna
gidiyordum Bir yandan bağlama kursuna
gidiyordum O da yetmedi gittim okul
başkanı oldum okul başkanı olurken
verdim şuydu son dönem her öğle arasında
müzik yayını yapacağım her öğle arası
Okulun bahçesinde şenlik olacak yaptım
bu kadar Bu yoğun temponun içinde bir de
gittim Okulda her öğle arası bir saat
kan ter içinde kalana kadar dans ettim
ve hiç yorulmadım hiç yoruldum
hatırlamıyorum Çünkü insan eğlenirken
Yorulmaz çocuklar oyundan yorulmazlar
Bu üniversite hayatım boyunca çalıştım
Üniversitesi Mimar Sinan Güzel Sanatlar
Üniversitesi sanat tarihi bölümünde
okudum ve görebildim önümü Çalışmaktan
başka bir çarem olmadığını sanat tarihi
çünkü ne yaptım ya Formula 1'de Ferrari
kızı olmaktan tutun
barda bağırma yat olmaya kadar
bir müzik festivallerinde ekip
yönetmekten Tutun bir çanta alıp bir
dergi için kapı kapı gezip reklam
toplamaya kadar markette kek yapıp bunu
insanlara dağıtmaktan tutun müzede
etkinlik yapmaya kadar mezun olduktan
sonra insan kaynakları yöneticisi olup
işletmeci olup Sonra gidip Uçakta hostes
olmaya kadar aklınıza gelebilecek her
türlü işi yaptım vardı çalıştığım
dönemlerde bir yandan oyunculuk eğitimi
alıyordu sabaha kadar barda çalışıyorum
sabah derse gidiyorum Tabii ki ilki
gider uyuyorum size ya uykusuz
kalıyordum ama yorulmuyorum Çünkü
istediğim şeyi yapmak için onurlu
gururlu bir mücadele verdiğimi
biliyordum Ben kimse benim için bir şey
yapsın diye Beklemedim ama zaman
içerisinde Onun için bir şeyler yapılan
insan oldum Çünkü çok çabaladım
çabaladığını da gördü etraf bu insanlar
hocalarım çabaladığını gördü beni özenle
yönlendirdiler işverenlerin çabaladığını
gördü beni yönetici yaptılar ailem
çabaladığını gördü arkamda durdu ki
benim ailem Karadenizli Biz de öyle
sahne dur televizyondur Bunlar Devrim
yaratan hareketler
sende sahnesinde çabalarım karşılığını
gördü bir insan sahneye çıkıp
karşısındaki başka bir insanı güldürmek
neşelendirmek niyetiyle bir şey
yapıyorsa bu niyet karşılığını bulur ve
ona gülünür o kişide Sahneye çıktığında
Pişman olmaz çünkü orada temiz bir niyet
var çok insani bir şey yani sen
karşındakinin yalnız yüzünde bir
gülümseme görmek istiyorsan Belki bu 50
kişi için geçerli olmaz ama iki kişi
senin bu niyetini yakalar Siz bir bağ
kurarsınız biz sonra bu bağ onları
rahatlatır o rahatlayan insanlar
Etrafındaki insanları rahatlatır bu
rahatlama yayılır sonra Bir bakarsınız
20 o Herkes artık bütün maskeleri
indirmiş gülüyor eğleniyor
tamamen kendi En azından benim
gösteririm için durum bu şekilde benim
sahnede başarılı olmamı sağlayan şey
kendimi tamamen açacak kadar kendimi
kabul etmek ve kendimi sevmek
queue elimden geleni bu olduğunu bilirim
Her zaman ben bu kadarını yapabiliyorum
şu anda Ama çabalıyorum kendimi
geliştirmek için çaba hiçbir zaman
bitmeyecek Bir de budur başarılı olmamı
sağlayan şey
sahnede seyirci ile bağ kurmak normal
hayatta bağ kurmak da aynı şey değil
şu sahneye çıkıp Eğer insanların
ilgisini istiyorsan Bu ilgiyi hak etmen
lazım Senden bunu bekler seyirci
saygısını hak etmen lazım gözüne
kulağına hitap etmen lazım sahnede
stand-up sahnesinde anlattığın şey değil
sadece materyalin kendinsin
yani çok büyük bir öz bu gerekiyormuş
gibi gözükse de aslında sahneye
çıktıktan sonra o gerekli olan özgüveni
çok daha fazlasını kazandırır insana
yapman gereken şey belli cesaret
edeceksin sahne atacaksın deneyeceksin
denerken öğreneceksin öğrendiklerinde
tekrar göster hazırlayacaksınız tekrar
sahneye çıkacaksın bununla hiç yılmadan
bunu bir süre devam ettireceksin
herkesin pür dikkat seni dinlediği ve
her Punch Line da Reaksiyon beklediğin
reaksiyonu almanı
sağlayan gösteri hazırlamak uzun bir
süre bu Uzun sürede Ben anladım ki
sadece şaka yazmakla bitmiyor bu iş
kendi kendinin işveren olmak zorundasın
kendime dedim ki kendinden emin gözükmek
istiyorsan kendinden emin ol bu düşük
nasıl olabilirsin ne zaman kendini
kendinden emin hissedersin Beğenilmek
istiyorsan kendine özen göster sağlıklı
beslen spor yap bakım ya Gezmiş görmüş
okumuş gözük iyi Gez gör oku
bir maske takılarak da yapılabilir
stand-up gösterisi yani başka bir gibi
davranabilirsin bir saat ama bence o
zaman bu tek kişilik oyun olur stand-up
gösterisi olmaktan çıkar Benim Tarzım O
yüzden yüzdeyüz kendim olmak kendi
hayatımda neye gülüyorsam içten bir
şekilde bunu seyirciyle paylaşmak bak
yani karşılığında bir Reaksiyon geleceği
düşüncesini tamamen terk etmek Bak
hayatımda en korktuğum şey yargılanmak
tığı en korktuğum yargıların üstüne ben
kendim atladım
en büyük eziklerim sahnedeki en iyi
şakaları mı oldu oldu ve yüzlerce
onlarca insan alkışlayarak Kahkahalar
atarak travmalarını güldü senelerce
Ben bunu yaparken aynı zamanda dünyayı
gezme hayalimi gerçekleştiriyorum hostes
olarak
gece sahneye çıkıyorum ol kış kıyamet bu
örgü takdir mutluluk Neşe sabah oluyor
Uçağa gidiyorum tuvalete temizliyorum
kleenex koymadım diye azar yiyorum
30-35 bin feat her gün
saatlerin geçiyor da iniyorsun her
indiğin yer dünyanın başka bir yere Her
gördüğünüz başka bir yüz Dünyada
gerçekten 7 buçuk milyar insan var Ve
gerçekten Biz o yedi buçuk milyar dan
sadece bir tanesiyiz
Ya bunu farkedince dedim ki sen kimsin
Niye senin acıların bu kadar büyük Niye
Senin aşkın bu kadar önemli Niye Senin
hayallerin bu kadar ulaşılmaz olsun diye
kendimi sorgulamaya başladım
hangi kilide girerse girsin açan üç tane
anahtarım var bunu sizlerle paylaşmaktan
onur ve mutluluk diliyorum birincisi bir
laf söz söz kabul et ve devam et
aslında ben bu lafı çok iyi biliyorum
ama bunun anahtarı O benim birşeyleri
deneyimle mem'den sonra gerçekleşti
kabul etmekle erişmek aynı şeydir
demiş Lao Tsu tanır mısınız kendisi
bilmem bundan 2500 yıl önce yaşamış ve
İnsanın insan olma ve doğa ile
ilişkisini o kadar Yalın bir şekilde
açıklamış ki siz hayatta kalmak için
gerekli bulduğunuz şeyleri hayatın özü
anlamamız dan gelen cehalet olduğunu
anlıyorsunuz adamı okuyunca diyor ki
kabul etmek ve erişmek aynı şeydir kabul
etmek mağlubiyet değildir kabul etmek
bir şeyin altında ezilmek değildir kabul
etmek ne olursa olsun geleni almaya açık
olmak ve gelen her şeyi göğüslemektir
bir 22 Ekim günü telefonum çaldı
sıa abimin hastaneye kaldırıldığını
öğrendim
şu sonra dayım beni geldi aldı biz
hastaneye gidene kadar Abim bu dünyadan
gitmişti ya
E tabi dayım Bunu duyunca o da
dayanamadı O da bu dünyadan gitti Ben
hayatımda bu kadar acıyı bir arada
yaşayıp bu kadar acıyla ne yapacağımı
hiç bilmediğim bir dönem hiç yaşamadım
ve tek bir şey öğretti bana bu acı
kabullenmeyi
kabullenmek yani sonucu kabullenmek
Çünkü ölümün bu kadar acı verici
olmasının sebebi bunu kabullenemem
işimiz herhangi bir şeyin sonucunu
kabullenmek bir Sorunsa Eğer sizin için
size bu Sorunu çözdünüz de ki
rahatlamayı hissettirir
ve bir kabul etmek sonuç ne olursa olsun
yola devam etmeyi sağlar
Bu ikinci anahtarım bir soru
ben bunu çok söylerim hayatta iki
seçeneğimiz var bir Umuda tutunmak iki
Acıya tutunmak hangisini seçeceksin
sıkıştığın noktada kendinize bunu
sorabilirsiniz Ben bunu da nereden çıkar
bir
insanın anlam arayışı diye bir kitap var
Viktor frankl yazmış Viktor frankl
norolog psikiyatrist aynı zamanda
Holokost an sana çıkıyor ve çıktıktan
sonra logoterapi diye bir terapi
yöntemini buluyor Ve bu kitapta da bu
yöntemi nasıl bulduğunu ve toplama
kampındaki deneyimlerini anlatıyor Yani
bu adam benden daha çok anlam aramış
ve diyor ki
eğer acı kaçınılmaz bir durum sabah saat
acıdan fayda sağlayarak acıya rağmen
anlam bulunabilir
gereksiz yere acı çekmek kahramanca bir
tutum değil mazoşist çevir yaklaşımıdır
Öyleyse bu anahtarı alalım ve canınız
çok yandığında kendinize sorun
acıya mı tutunacağım Umuda ama
üçüncüsü bir oyun oyun kendimi çok çok
hissettiğim zamanlarda oynadığım bir
oyun yürürken oynamanızı tavsiye bu
şöyle omuzlarınızı biraz geri alıp Şimdi
de yapabilirsiniz isterseniz şimdi
omuzları biraz geriye atıp buraya
konsantre olup göğsünüzde Iron Man
reaktörü varmış gibi düşüneceksiniz
burada bir reaktör var
Palladium çekirdeği var içinde füzyonu
suyla size can veriyor Hayat veriyor
cayır cayır canlı olmanızı sağlıyor
şimdi Iron Man'in buna hayatta kalmak
için ihtiyacı vardı Iron Man Iron Man
yapan şey reaktör değildi reaktör
sayesinde hayatta kalıp tasarladığı zırh
ve mücadeleye devam etmesiydi Biz
hayattayız zaten bizim reaktörü
ihtiyacımız yok ve oraya aktörden çok
daha iyi çalışan bir şey var burada
Kalbimiz kalbin manyetik alanı beyinden
beş bin kat daha fazla
Ben odama buradan buraya çevirdim
buradan yaşamaya başlayınca başardığımı
hissetmeye cips ettim
çok sevdim burun hep açtım hiçbir zaman
kırılmaktan korkmadım kırılmaktan
korkmayıp kalbimi ne kadar açtıysam o
kadar çok korkunç dışarıya çıktı mı
hangi işi yaptıysam gönlümde yüreğimle
yaptım
Arkadaşlıkta da ilişkide ailede kimi
sevdiysem kalbimle yüreğimle sevdim
şimdi ve başarılı olmuşum ki şu anda
buradayım
Biz o yüzden herkese Kalbi ile yaşamayı
kalbiyle sevmeyi kalbiyle öğrenmeyi bir
şey isteyecek s kalbiyle istemeye
tavsiye ediyorum ve beni dinlediğiniz
için teşekkür ediyorum
şimdi bir şarkıyı çalacağım size
şe Eğer alabilirsem gitar gelirse
benim gelip almam gerekiyor gitarı bize
A101
Evet bu benim şarkım
Yılmaz bir beste
kendi kendime yaptığım bir şarkı benim
ütopyam anlatıyor
e geliyor musunuz şimdi dedim ya
Ya
sen ben
şu anda
aç uzağa
bir sevgi
Yok
anlatmam Derdimi
kimse
sevser
düşünmeden
özgürce ceviri k k
anlar Dünya
bu dünyada
o
ölünce
ise
a.c.e. beni
çok yam da iyi
Bahar Dört Mevsim
Sen şarkı
maskeler
sahneler
gelmezsin
lütfen serum İyi ki
ninden hafifler sin
sevdim sanır insan
olmak zordur
bilirsin ya